crumble came in and is crushing with
cookies 5 out of six cookies are new
every week you know what hasn't done
that yet is ice cream stores I haven't
seen ice cream stores switch their all
of their flavors except for just like
chocolate and vanilla every week they
don't do that we order the crumble
cookies just because we're like let's
try these ones with that variety extend
your LTV how can we just create
consistently rotating new flavors the
more options you give someone the more
total Food they'll eat Oreos figured
that out it was like okay well we'll
just [__] put limited flavors every
weekend and some people were like oh
let's see what carrot cake Oreos tastes
like